please welcome jeffrey goodman
so jeffrey uh here we have
norway number one
sweden congratulations yes
sweden number two and i think britain
number three should be very british
well you can you you're you're american
or british american yes i know but you
live here so
yeah you hold yourself uh i'm just going
to put you in the right way
american yes and you're on 12th
12th me too by the way i'm american
living in britain so
there we are are you happy about that
being american paying their taxes
i'm not happy about paying taxes in two
countries no but
this is this is about prosperity yes and
it's about
measuring prosperity and and first of
all how do you do that
well it's hard you know we're we're
grappling with this we we have an
institute here in london we have an
index and first of all to say obviously
it's not a hard science right this is
not
a math problem or an engineering
question
but uh here's how this comes about we've
had for about
three quarters of a century this thing
called gdp right
and that was the uh people called it the
statistic to trump all statistics it was
the way
to measure the wealth and well-being of
a country
and then all of a sudden a few years ago
in different countries around the world
people uh woke up one day and said well
wait a second there's more to life than
wealth right
so there's other things like health care
education governance safety security
so there's a new area of research like
ours
our institute trying to figure out how
do you measure these things so it's a
a mix of objective and subjective uh
data
opinion polling and so forth so it's an
approximation to
to to try to figure out what constitutes
a healthy prosperous society
but would you be able to single out one
factor
that is more important than others well
we have
eight factors that we look at and we
actually
invite you to decide what you would
think is more important if you want to
play a game you can go to
www.prosperity.com and you can look at
your country
and you can manipulate the data a little
bit but
governance is very important health is
very important
uh entrepreneurship and opportunity is
very important are you in a country or
space where you feel like
there's real equal opportunity and you
can initiate something and make
something happen create your own success
so give us a brief uh idea of how the
world looks
through these eyes well first of all
a lot of it validates what experience
would tell you anyway
the top 30 countries in the world uh 28
are democracies
right with rule of law with economic
freedom with free competitive press with
independent judiciary
the bottom 30 are all either
dictatorships
or war-torn because peace matters you
know if you're in civil war
it's hard to be prosperous and have
coherence in a healthy society
but generally speaking rule of law
accountable government
uh good justice system hannibal
government
accountable
why is norway number one i mean the
scandinavian
countries so so you're the world
champions right we have
norway and denmark are we allowed to
mention denmark on the show
and denmark and sweden are the top three
so what do we know
we know that they uh relatively small
countries this is the case where small
is a good thing and in small countries
it's an advantage
we know the case of norway they're
natural resources but natural resources
can be a curse look at saudi arabia
other places
but when they're managed well
intelligently and judiciously that's an
advantage
when their societies as you have a great
compliment that have high levels of
tolerance
that's very positive and then in the
case you know if i could you know
compliment and pick on the swedes for a
second
there was a time not so long ago that
the world was very critical of sweden
because people said
bloated welfare state and regulated
economy and lack of flexibility
but the swedes were adaptable and
changed and moderated and reformed
so combination of those things tends to
result
in you know a decent prosperous healthy
society as best we can tell now if you
want to tell us that our data is wrong
and you're very unhappy there in norway
and conflicted that's okay too
but but in real in relational terms in
relative terms to other countries
norway denmark sweden turn out very well
autonomy
we like being rooted in something you
know it's a family or it's a community
or tradition but we don't like being
root less and then the third thing i
would say is purpose
right it could be spirituality it could
be children
it could be a political